we asked Pompeo to join us tonight and
though he really turns down a televised
interview he refused to come we hope he
will reconsider in the meantime we are
happy to be joined tonight by New York
Post columnist Brandon Devine Miranda
thank you so much for coming on I don't
think we've paused long enough to
consider what this means after 60 years
when every person involved is dead we
can't see
classified information about a maybe the
pivotal event in modern American history
and now we know why
well Tucker look you've laid it out
really well and you know it used to be
that conservatives like me dismissed uh
theories from the left about JFK's
assassination as just left-wing
conspiracy theories but over time uh I
think that the left looks as if they
were quite justified in not trusting the
intelligence services and I think the
wmd pretext for the Iraq War was a red
pill a slowly Dawning red pill for me
and so now you just have to look just on
on a really basic level you just look at
the fact that 30 years ago Congress in a
unanimous bipartisan uh unequivocal
unambiguous decision said that these all
the JFK files have to be made public
absolutely no reason to keep them back
as you say it's almost 60 years ago
everybody involved is dead you're not
worried about selling reputations or
unmasking a spy overseas no there can
only be two reasons for it one is that
you're trying to protect the CIA against
um allegations or Revelations that it
knew more than it made out about Lee
Harvey Oswald it had a huge file on him
they were investigating him or in
connect in in contact with him before
the assassination and they didn't do
enough to save JFK or protect the
president but but you know is that
enough to really keep this secret going
for 60 years I mean the terrible Dawning
recognition is that really this is about
as you said protecting the institution
if the CIA was involved in that
assassination that is the reason that
you would want to keep that from the
American people because the fury that
would erupt and this is a bipartisan
Fury it'd be the one thing that would
unite Americans is a absolute rage at
this unaccountable spy agency that is uh
has decided that it is going to get
involved in murdering assassinating the
duly elected American president for what
reason
um you know there would be such a clean
out of the CIA I don't know if it would
even survive and so the trust in our
institutions is already at Rock Bottom I
think it's a mistake for Mike Pompeo not
to come on your show because all this
does is fuel more conspiracy theories
the truth is the best disinfectant and
if the CIA did do this was involved 60
years ago then it needs to come clean we
need to have a reckoning
and just to be clear that was the
assessment of someone we spoke to who
was directly and personally familiar
with the contents of these documents not
someone who read it on the internet
this is someone who had access to the
documents and I have to say I don't
understand and I agree with you secrecy
abets evil and the more secrecy you have
the more evil you're likely to have so
we should minimize the amount of secrecy
as a general matter but I don't
understand how John Brennan can go on
NBC News every day he was on today and
no one pauses and asks like what is this
exactly 60 years really and don't give
me the sources in methods BS by the way
son like we're we're adults here what's
the real reason why does no one ask him
that
well the more we see characters from the
CIA like John Brennan like those 51
former intelligence officials who signed
that scurrilous letter about Hunter
Biden being Russian disinformation uh
the more the the less impressive they
look these people are in the shadows for
a reason because if you actually saw who
they were look at John Brennan would you
knowing what we know now about him would
you really entrust him uh to run the the
country's Premier spy agency to have
such power to run around the world
intervening in other countries elections
no so uh I I just don't know what good
it does us to have those kind of
malevolent people having so much power
and using it in our name and causing us
all great harm because we don't know
what they're doing that's right
transparency can fix it it's the only
thing they can't and I appreciate your
assessment team Marina Divine of the
neuropost thank you
thanks to her subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight